I love that you're down to do it before
you can figure out why you're fighting
yeah I was trying to understand what was
happening the whole time as you're just
walking as I'm walking up it feels very
Hawaiian but the homies behind me was
cool it was cool it was like I was
leading a pack of 10 people I was like
this is cool man and they don't even
figure it out either they didn't know
why too they're just like
blind lady in the blind
[Music]
all right so we gotta fight that
happened over in Hilo Hilo Beach Park in
Hawaii dude they have the best fights
808 scraps baby when you whenever you
see like a street fight in like Hawaii
yeah they're the best how come they're
so respectful one and then as soon as
they crack somebody or someone gets hurt
they just like they don't like keep
going on the ground they don't jump
anybody yeah and they they could fight
bro yeah everyone actually gets into
position they don't just throw Haymakers
I wouldn't want to get a fight with
anybody you've been in a lot of fights
in Hawaii when you live there no just
like three or four of them and it's just
kids you know back then I didn't know
how to fight one was with a micronesian
yeah why are you pointing at me
you're a local now thank you
I like Michael I like everybody is there
a lot of micronesians in Hawaii
so many of them yeah so what's the deal
what's to do with Micronesia
Hey Joe what's the deal with Michael
man I got coffee all over my table
you hiring one what's the deal with them
I saw this fight happened the
interesting thing in the story is not
the fight but the retaliation I'm gonna
show you the actual uh disagreement that
happened what the [__] happened to this
oh snap so there's some teenagers that
got into an altercation but then the mom
started fighting right
[Music]
which one's the mom look how beautiful
the background goes too
fighting in paradise in paradise yeah
so the moms are trying to stop them
providing but they end up fighting
themselves right wait which one's the
moms is it the one in the green the one
in the middle green is one of them so uh
they're trying to do the good thing it
doesn't but you cross the line it
doesn't get that bad but what happens
later uh gets a little bit worse they
end up uh retaliating later oh I've seen
this one they got arrested yeah yeah
yeah yeah so check out this part of the
video
well you guys got involved yeah so six
dudes roll up and they find this car
they start beating up the car yeah dude
with a bat smashes the [__] right there
they're beating up dudes
or the it's dudes on dudes or no it's
basic so what happened that's family
that's dudes on kids there's like miners
in the car but here's the twist it's a
Samoan kit so it looks like 40. what do
you think the twist is I don't know
that's a lot of pressure
I don't know what's the twist it's just
the dash there's something wrong with
that situation there's something wrong
with that you mean they [__] up their
own family members because they they
thought it was the bad guys no they
definitely did think that was the bad
guys but it was just a random car with
with kids that had nothing to do with
them so they just smashed up a car
micronesians man
I'll tell you a joke
it's getting out of hands so the problem
is that like so these are the six dudes
that attacked the car and two of those
guys are dads so basically that would be
attack on a minor like as an adult I
didn't know Edgar haircuts were going to
Hawaii too damn man no it's called the
Bangla haircut
the bang boys
wait no it's like the bangle like the
like the bang
[Music]
it's like a it's like a Vibe or look
it's like a swag for like people who can
fight and [__] yeah oh there's a fighter
yeah like a banger yeah not a gang
banger
like a bang okay
um yeah so that was the wrong uh the
wrong guys
completely huh how sad man so they just
pulled up on a random car at what point
did they realize
like after the fact I know they may they
might still not realize right you just
got a bunch of kids in the backseat
enjoy their leaking powder paper
what if those kids were like really bad
kids or something you say they deserved
it you son of a [__] it's like yeah
it's like a weird karmic thing they
should check their criminal records yeah
just see and they're just like they're
sweet kids they're just the best
that's okay
but they're not in a Mustang dude oh
yeah that's like a they're not they're
not in a Hertz Mustang that's like a
[__] 2004 Accord yeah
I rented that when I was back there and
they shattered a windshield yeah with a
bat that's crazy that's super wacky out
of control so these kids got taken to
the hospital for like injuries
lacerations
um they got cut up and stuff yeah
and the person that's filming that
retaliation is actually like I think
like a friend of the guys in the car no
way so instead of stopping it nah bro
she's too scared you're gonna stop or
maybe they're like oh they deserved it
she was like dude they're bad kids
so you're an advocate of like if someone
was a bad person if they mistakenly get
attacked it's Justified uh a little bit
you don't have friends where sometimes
you're like you're such an [__]
right you don't have friends where
sometimes you're like you're such an
[__] something's coming to you like
I'm not gonna [__] you up but like
you're an [__] and then you see them
get [__] up and you're like I knew it
uh your time was coming yeah yeah I
believe that how often do you see fights
like that in Hawaii
I don't know I'm not I don't live there
I mean when you were there oh you don't
live there but when I was there uh it
was every week every week every week
after high school it was like yo Mimi
and uh what do you call [__] Lola park
or media meters is oh something going
down and it's always one-on-ones or is
it just like there's a desk one on one
place to fight like you guys always
fighting yeah yeah we always pakalolo
park or meters in Salt Lake there's
always a park we would always just squab
doesn't that mean marijuana yep
we call apocalolo park because that's
where everyone would smoke yeah
everybody
there too
one time I had to go my cousin comes I
was like yo some guy wants to fight you
and I'm like what the [__] what did I do
I'm over here I was like [__] it
everyone's like you gotta go so you
don't even know why no we don't know if
someone challenges you you just do it
yep and back in the day I was just
walking towards Long's drug and I looked
behind me I'm like damn I can't believe
I had a fight right now I look behind me
there's like 10 of my homies go get them
and I'm like oh you know I'm actually
hyped right now so let's do this [__] so
I walk up the park and I see my enemy I
see my opponent and he has his family
but I didn't realize how [__] tall he
was until I got closer to him you've
never seen him before no I've never seen
him why does he want to fight just for
my cousin who was saying my cousin can
beat your ass a bit
that's the word
my friend might be able to beat your ass
yeah I didn't find out until like five
years later
oh yo whatever happened to that fight my
cousin
I said I said my cousin could beat your
ass and I was like what the [__] it took
me five years to ask yeah because so
what happened so I'll go up to him and
I'm getting closer to him and I'm like
damn this food's tall I'm getting my ass
beat but [__] it so [__] pose up and
then you hear auntie in the corner yeah
you [__] us
I was like
I'm glad in my head I'm like Auntie
break it up I don't want to fight this
foreign
yeah and I was like what's going on I
was like come on break the fight and
Auntie comes in the middle of it he's
like you [__] us get away
look at everybody you look stupid and I
was like yeah
[Laughter]
slowly we started slowly walking back to
the park all right so nothing happened
nothing happened oh man thank God for
the Auntie really no yeah thank God that
fool was big what if you were thinking
[__] like he's pretty confident man
he's smaller than me but he's not
backing down like usually I just use my
size yeah that's one story
oh man
cousin wasn't there that's the problem
he didn't even attend my cousin had to
go home because my auntie called him a
home
where's Richard
yeah he's probably just giggling the
worst cousin so there's a general
respect for like aunties when they run
out and [__] everyone got to stop doing
this aunties and uncles pulls up you
gotta listen
um second respect he's like yo listen to
them disrespect man as soon as you have
a problem with the aunties and alcohol
then oh
so yeah with their family now we were
just one Auntie away from that being
prevented huh yep yeah rolled out they
probably would all stop though yep I'm
trying to smoke some meth over here shut
the [__] up
behind Blockbuster at that time I don't
know how the [__] you hear us dude I'm
about she's all moral about it she goes
I can't hit this [__] pipe with you
kids
I'm trying to get higher peace I know
that's also cool that she's responsible
like she was like I better [__]
squash this you know I'm gonna smoke
those ice but like you guys better chill
I'm grateful I was happy yeah because I
was just trying to dance a little bit in
the park and then now I gotta fight like
what the [__] happened yeah that line in
the front of Long's Drugs yeah yeah I
love that you're down to do it before
you can figure out why you're fighting
yeah I was trying to understand what was
happening the whole time
as I'm walking up it feels very Hawaiian
but the homies behind me it was cool it
was cool it was like I was leading a
pack of 10 people I was like this is
cool man and they don't even figure it
out either they didn't know why too
they're just like wait it's just like
the blind leading the blind in the
situation Judo when we do fight
everyone's respectful and everyone
yeah they're throwing leg kicks like an
MMA I don't and they fight a flip-flop
suits they find in sandals and [__] no
that's why we wear flip-flop because if
we have to fight we have to
what's up
everybody damn that's [__] crazy I'm
gonna tell you these are the Hawaiian
music a [__] fight they got that
Warrior spirit in them you know that's
just real dude you can see it especially
in like the MMA like professional yeah
you see them like how they fight is
there a top is there a top fighter oh
man okay the God yeah he's the dude
right now that's your you love him I
love them big fan and beforehand BJ Penn
yeah BJ yeah he's like one of the goats
and then all the all the Hawaiian dudes
on the ninth Island who fight out of
Vegas there's like [__] like 50 of
them
there's a bunch oh they actually call
Vegas a ninth Island that's the real
name yeah oh cause everybody lives there
I went to the dogs you made that up
right now I went to a Don's like
training thing because he has a
franchise out there and then I could
have sworn I was in Hawaii because the
guy that runs his uh like the Vegas
franchise of deep end Fitness is a
fighter from Hawaii and then it's him
like 12 other Hawaiian dudes and
Hawaiians they always roll with their
families so it's 12 dudes all swimming
around all the ladies in the bleachers
with babies and babies just running
around the
pools oh yeah probably talking about
spam musubis and food what are you
trying to get after that
that's how it is planning to go to
Zippy's yeah there's no zippies in Vegas
though they don't have anything they're
going to bring one they're building it
right now yeah you can see the Zippy's
on the building yeah it's emotional time
for him
you know they were supposed to build it
like it was supposed to be here like
five years ago but it's by Hawaiians so
it takes longer they're taking a long
time
all right they gotta get the funds right
too you know oh yeah and he's in the
back cooking it up
[Music]
foreign